[Música]
y
los viernes por el futuro regresan a
francia después del receso del cob y de
19 con varias acciones hoy pero también
mañana sábado básicamente este viernes
hay debates en las escuelas en torno a
la crisis climática y mañana una
treintena de eventos en todo el país
bajo el lema en contra de los proyectos
inútiles de impuestos y en contra de las
empresas seveso que son aquellas que
tienen un alto riesgo de accidente grave
justamente cuando se cumple un año del
incendio en la fábrica química lubrizol
en el norte de francia que lanzó la
atmósfera 10.000 toneladas de productos
tóxicos sino que otras acciones hay una
cicletada por ejemplo en dijon una
acción de desobediencia civil en león y
en grenoble una movilización de
pancartas en clamor feroz y en parís lo
que han llamado camps clima que es
básicamente la ocupación de un lugar
público con pancartas alusivas a la
lucha contra el calentamiento global los
líderes del movimiento saben que deben
reinventarse que las manifestaciones ya
no conducen a nada que el clima no es
una prioridad en estos momentos por eso
llamar a la gente a estar en resistencia
e inventar un nuevo mundo
[Música]
las manifestaciones del friday for
future han vuelto a bélgica tras el
llamamiento de la activista sueca greta
thunberg a que se retomarán tras el pico
de la pandemia debido a las
restricciones por el coronavirus ha
habido un número de jóvenes que sí se
han manifestado en el centro de bruselas
pero en lugar de marchar por toda la
ciudad como venía siendo habitual
simplemente se han mostrado sentados con
pancartas en forma de protesta además ha
sido una manifestación mucho menos
numerosa de lo habitual para así
mantener las distancias de seguridad a
pesar de la pandemia de kobe 19 muchas
ciudades europeas han cambiado por
completo de hecho en bruselas se han
ampliado todos los carril bici también
se han ampliado los espacios para los
peatones y se han restringido los coches
en muchas de estas ciudades a pesar de
todo los jóvenes insisten en que no es
suficiente en que el cambio climático
aún sigue ahí a pesar de la pandemia de
echo bélgica ha registrado uno de los
septiembres más secos que se recuerdan y
con una ola de calor que nunca había
ocurrido tan tarde en el calendario
[Música]
en washington se han reanudado
oficialmente las actividades de fidesur
y future o viernes para el futuro
incluirá varias manifestaciones
pacíficas y silenciosas en puntos muy
importantes de la ciudad como frente al
congreso de los eeuu a la estación de
trenes conocida como unión station
también frente a la casa blanca durante
los próximos meses el objetivo principal
es llamar la atención a los gobiernos
locales pero en este caso al congreso en
específico para que tomen medidas para
luchar en contra del calentamiento
global esto también busca que eeuu
vuelva al acuerdo de parís y que los dos
candidatos a la presidencia que están
actualmente en esta carrera por llegar a
la casa blanca adopten políticas en sus
agendas que tengan que ver con la
protección medioambiental
[Música]